how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have to talk about one of the
biggest Easter eggs in Avengers endgame
and that is how Avengers in game sets up
Namor to enter the MCU if you haven't
seen Avengers in game and are worried
about spoilers don't worry we won't
really be going into spoilers in this
video I'm just going to be talking about
one sentence that is said in the
beginning of avengers endgame that
doesn't really have anything to do with
the rest of the movie so no need to
worry about spoilers and if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe I'm
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway and
a glow-in-the-dark fan o spanning
giveaway by globe I both the giveaway
ends at the end of this month so one day
left I'll talk more about it at the end
so namor the sub-mariner is a character
who fans have wanted to see enter the
MCU for a really long time now name war
is the ruler of Atlantis and he has
mutant genes and he was teased before in
Iron Man 2 Nick Fury is meeting with
Iron Man to talk about the Avengers
initiative and while they talk nearby is
a map of the world and on this map it
has markers of people that they are
monitoring across the world and one of
these markers is right in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean so many people
believe that this is a reference to
Namor and Atlantis so that was the first
Easter Egg to Namor and recently Kevin
Feige has been talking a lot about
bringing Namor into the MCU and now we
have another huge easter egg in Avengers
in-game an Avengers in game Black Widow
is leading a meeting with some of the
other heroes who are monitoring the
world
Okoye is in Wakanda and she says that
there was an underwater earthquake Black
Widow asked how she's going to handle it
and she says it's an underwater
earthquake we handle it by not handling
it this is definitely a reference to
Namor the Submariner there is no other
reason why they would put this in the
movie except to reference Namor because
otherwise it doesn't really make any
sense this is a three hour movie in
which they crammed a lot into everything
is super intentional with this movie so
this appears to be a big Easter egg
towards Namor the Submariner and it
looks like they're setting him up to be
the villain in Black Panther to a coy
mentions that the earthquake was off of
the coast of Africa in her saying we
handle it by not handling it could mean
one of two things one it could mean that
it's simply an earthquake and there's
nothing to do about it however I
personally think that she knows its name
or in the comics Wakanda and Atlantis
have a long history of being at war with
one another so a cuy could know that
this is in fact a name war but knows not
to interfere with the underwater
Atlanteans Black Panther 2 would also be
the best bet of introducing Namor
because of the rights that are
associated with name war unfortunately
Marvel and Disney don't own the rights
to have a name or solo movie however
they do have the rights to use him in
other movies this is just like the new
Hulk he cannot have his own solo movie
but he can be thrown into Avengers films
and thor ragnarok so we can't have a
solo name or movie yet but we can't
introduce him in black panther 2 which
would be the perfect opportunity because
again atlantis and what kondeh are known
for constantly being at war with one
another and if you think about it it
would be a super cool movie two hidden
civilizations going to battle with one
another an introducing Namor into the
MCU could lead the way to introducing
mutants and that certainly seems to be
the way that this is going because again
this Easter Egg is a reference to Namor
it was put in this movie for a very
specific reason he's somebody that the
fans have wanted to see into the MCU for
a very long time now and again Kevin
Feige has teased about him entering the
MCU very recently so that's it for this
Namor Easter egg in Avengers endgame and
how he could be the villain in black
panther 2 so let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
and again another reminder about my
giveaway I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark
famous painting by glow by beau you can
also find more of his work at globe
abode com I'll put the link in the
description down below if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
wolf wolf
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby
now you're number